uh alex smith retires after 16 nfl
seasons
one of the most compelling stories we've
seen ever as it relates to a comeback
the horrific broken leg the horrific
series of infections and surgeries and
the guy first was going to lose his leg
potentially then we realized he could
have lost his life the images that are
out there of what that leg looked like
at one point from all of the surgical
procedures and the complications and the
infections
unbelievable that he was able to come
back and play crowning achievement
something he should never be forgotten
for and i think something we will all
people have suggested they should name
the comeback player of the year award
after him and i could get behind that
that's how impressive it was but beyond
that the guy's been a damn good
quarterback yeah and he's been through
that revolving door offensive
coordinators teams
good enough to get to playoff games had
some great postseason performances that
will be forgotten unfortunately
especially since he'll primarily be
remembered for his comeback from the leg
injury yeah but he decides to retire
chris sounds like
there was no path to the field
and when there's no path to the field
there's a different level of
compensation you're gonna get and given
that the guys made nearly 190 million
dollars
it's probably not worth it to do all the
stuff you need to do to be a backup
quarterback and get what three four
million dollars max yeah no i mean i i
would i would think there wasn't a lot
of play you know everybody would love to
have a guy like alex smith on their
roster there's no doubt about that but
you know like we talked about a lot
during the end of the year and
everything like that it just is a little
scary
i i know you and i we're not alone in
that thought and hoping that like hey
maybe i'd like to just see you quit i'm
i'm nervous watching you play i think
there was that aspect and i'm sure
evaluators of course saw that same thing
and that that is scary that way but i
mean to to the point here with alex
smith i mean perseverance is what i'll
think about with him always you know
in two different ways one overcoming
this injury like what you said is it's a
great story
i could get behind him being you know
the comeback player of the year name two
behind that all of that too but then
even early in his career the
perseverance there he was the number one
pick in the draft it was strugglesville
early on there with the 49ers they
weren't good he looked like a bust for a
first pick all these issues he kind of
hung in there continued to work they get
jim harbaugh they finally get the team
turned around and it turned his career
around because he continued to hang in
there and i i respect that greatly so i
got great respect for the guy and uh you
know congratulations on the retirement
alex
i think he had a different offensive
coordinator pretty much every year from
2005. until 2011
jim harbaugh shows up they get to the
nfc championship game but for a couple
of muff punts they could have gone to
the super bowl that year and faced the
new england patriots in super bowl 46
and that the game
before the nfc championship the saints
game
that divisional round contest
was awesome yes it was one of those few
games where as you're watching it you
know this is special this is memorable
the back and forth the great run by alex
smith the saints stay in it the 49ers
eventually win the game the touchdown
pass to vernon davis just awesome stuff
here's some of that game from 10 seasons
ago there he goes around the left edge
for the long touchdown run and i mean
the guy had determination he had grit
and he knew how to get the job done and
then
and then he was done the next year
colin kaepernick comes in when he
suffers a concussion and that's it they
move on to kaepernick he takes him to
the super bowl he gets traded to the
chiefs chiefs do well with them and then
they get patrick
and he has one more year and he gets
traded to washington and then the injury
happens so he he really did have an
underrated career
postseason that game that you know the
post script on the game against the
colts in 2013 was the colts came back
from a 3810 deficit in the second half
yeah
he was great in that game yeah alex
smith was great in that loss right no i
i know i mean there's some memorable
there's some memorable moments as far as
you know the playoffs you know the
saints game like you just said is the
game that i'll always remember if you
give me one game to think about alex
smith that is going to be it there's no
doubt so many big plays it's a lot of
fun to watch you're right as you were
watching it you're going man this is
special can these teams keep answering
each other all that you know and and to
you know to his credit
yeah he was dealt a big blow there i
mean they were a super bowl team
obviously and they thought hey they
couldn't get over the hump so they went
with kaepernick and then really it was
the same thing that happened with them
in kansas city
and the guy just handled it as
professional as you can in both in both
instances and just continue to move on
with life and go other places and be
successful and do that and
you know the fact that he just always
got up off the canvas keeps fighting no
matter what i really respect that any
player or person and that's really what
alex smith stands for
and it's this strange kind of curse that
he had on his career where he was good
enough yeah
to get you consistently in the
conversation
but he was regarded in multiple places
as not being good enough to get you over
the hump that's right there are plenty
of quarterbacks out there
that would love to be that guy yeah
they're struggling just to be the guy to
get you in the conversation he's getting
you well into the conversation
and you know it's almost like the
mindset that john elway had when he
fired john fox after
getting close
to the super bowl and getting to you
know you can't get me over the hump you
get me close but you can't get me over
the hump right and that that that that
fact that you're tantalized by being
that close it makes you impatient and
that's what happened in san francisco
it's what happened it didn't really
happen in san francisco the way it
happened in kansas city because they
drafted kaepernick before alex smith
really took off right but in kansas city
that's definitely what happened they
they did a hard look in the mirror at
the team
and alex smith is good enough to keep us
in this final eight
we need somebody who's going to
consistently keep us in the final four
and in the final two and that's what
they did yeah no well it makes you like
it makes you wonder
how different things would have been
right if there wasn't the drop puns in
that nfc championship game would the
stigma and perception around him be
different if they did get to the super
bowl that year you know that to where
maybe you don't you know you don't think
that way of him going forward and maybe
the team doesn't think about you know
kaepernick starting that next year when
when smith does get hurt and all those
things i mean it is definitely one of
those what-if moments of his life but
yeah ultimately i mean i think you kind
of hit it like he was really good he
could take you to the playoffs but he
needed a little help getting to the
super bowl he wasn't going to be the
driving force to get that team there and
i think ultimately that's what made
kansas city draft patrick mahomes right
i mean it's that pittsburgh playoff game
if i remember correctly where it was a
close football game but i can still
remember watching film of that game
going damn
you know there was some plays there to
be had they they probably should have
won this game and all that and i would
think that's what led kansas city and
andy reid to go wait we need to find a
little bit more of an aggressive big arm
type quarterback and that's why they
made the moves to to trade and get
mahomes in the draft
that was the game that got moved to
prime time yeah ice storm kansas city it
was a sunday afternoon game on nbc and
it got slid into the evening and uh yeah
and and that was a gutsy move by andy
reid
uh alex smith an excellent quarterback
one of the better quarterbacks of the
past 16 years and i looked it up
yesterday
other than kickers and punters because
there's a few of them still floating
around 2005 draft with alex smith
retiring the three
non-specialists who are left roger
rodgers right richie incognito wow ryan
fitzpatrick and frank gore frank gore
size with another team okay well those
are some legends right there really i
mean that really is some them big names
and yeah that's that's a lot of a lot of
football a lot of football and richie
incognito man i forgot he's that old
holy cow that's amazing that he's
hanging around still
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports